Herkese merhabalar ben Deniz bolkan
severcan Efendim size Öncelikle
Merhabalar yanda göremedim kusura
bakmayın
[Alkış]
1966 yılında İzmir'de doğmuş sonra da şu
anda 56 yaşına kadar gelmiş birisiyim
daha önce bir TX konuşmasına katılmıştım
böyle çok çalıştım programlar yaptım
kendime slaytlar hazırladım vesair
şeyler yaptım Fakat burada bir
kronometre var şurada Siz görmüyorsunuz
ama bir baktım ona 3 dakikam kalmış da
anlatmam gereken 30 dakikalık şey var o
yüzden bugün
kendimle ilgili size Birazcık bilgi
vermeye Bu Yaşadığım hayatın içerisinden
Belki biraz bir şeyler
yakalayabilirsiniz diye irtica ile
konuşmak üzerine çıktım dedim ya
İzmirliyim 1966 yılında orada doğdum bir
avukat ve bir ev adamı
babanın ve Bir annenin çocuğu
İzmir'e Özel Türk Koleji
Bilmiyorum Biliyor musunuz Bir özel
okulda okudum
Çok ciddi bir müzik yeteneğim vardı o
zamanlar ilk önce Trompet çalmaya
başladım Arkasından da kontürbasyon
eğitimi gördüm Bu arada da tabii babanın
Avukat olmasından dolayı da bir hukukçu
ailenin içerisinde yaşadım büyüdüm Eğer
ne kadar böyle modern bir aile olsak da
yine o Avukat hukuk yapısının evin
içerisinde böyle derin hissedildiği bir
evde büyüdüm ben
kuzenim benden 6 yaş büyük Avukat oldu
babam Avukat kolejde okurken bir kız
arkadaşım vardı Ee ben bir sene Sınıfta
kaldım O da Avukat oldu Yani bütün
şartlar benim Avukat olmama doğru böyle
yoğun bir şekilde geliyor Ben
1983 yılında üniversite sınavlarında ki
o zaman hatırlar mısınız Bilmiyorum
belki hatırlayanlar vardır ama
çocukların bildiğini zannetmiyorum yine
iki basamaklı bir sınava giriyorduk 18
tane tercih yapıyorduk İzmir'i bilenler
gayet
İzmir'de
Alsancak'ta İzmir sineması vardı orada 9
Eylül Üniversitesi'nin İşletme Fakültesi
vardı Biz İzmirliler de En sevdiğimiz
yer olduğu için oraya bayılırdık ben 18
tercih yaptım üniversite sınavlarında 17
tanesi hukuk Ama üçüncü tercihim işletme
İzmir'deki işletme fakültesini yazmıştım
Ve tabii ki orayı
kazandımdan sonra da al sancaktaki
İşletme Fakültesi Buca'ya taşındı
oraya da Hukuk Fakültesi geldi
Dolayısıyla ben dışarıda kaldım bir
şekilde işte babama anlattım durumu
Oğlum işletme nereden çıktı dedi Dedim
baba Vallahi Alsancak diye yazmıştır Ben
falan filan derken bir yoluna bir
konduğunu buldum Seriye nasıl hukuk
fakültesine girerim diye atladım
İstanbul'a gittim çünkü bütün derdim
aslında konservatuvara girebilmekte Ama
bunu bir türlü ittiremiyordum itiraf
etmem lazım ki İstanbul Üniversitesi
Devlet konservatuarının sınavlarına
girdim Aslında mesele bir sene Orada
okuyup tekrar geri Gelip buradan hukuk
fakültesine devam etmekte ama giriş o
giriş patladı gitti işte hayatım tiyatro
sahnelerinde Ondan sonra devam etmeye
başladı ilginç bir şey oldu bu arada
şehir tiyatrolarının sınavlarına girdim
ben şehir tiyatrolarının sınavlarında da
bir figüran sınavıydı
sınavından sonra da sevgili Önder bari
orkinsonra şefi benim figüranlık
yaparken görünce ne işin var burada
senin gel çabuk orkestraya dedi
hayatımın ciddi bir bölümünde orkestrada
geçti Bununla ilgili de bazı şeyler
anlatacağım Biraz sonra ama şimdi
konservatuara girdikten sonra çok önemli
bir şey geldi başıma çoğu insanı
anlatmadığım çoğu insanın bilmediği bir
şey o zamanlar İstanbul'da Taksim'de bir
yer vardı Milli Eğitimin kitaplarını
satardı orası hepimiz paramız yettiğince
giderdik Orada iki kitapları alır ve
oradaki kitapları birbirimize
paylaşırdık Ben o zamanlar bir kitap
okudum
okuduğum bir tane kitap benim hayatımı
öyle bir değiştirdi ki bu kitap Alfred
dövün diye isimli Fransız Bir şairin
aynı zamanda böyle yarı filozof gibi bir
Adamın Günlüğü güncesi
gün içerisine öyle bir şey yazmış ki
adam diyor ki; her Umudun her düşüncenin
her aşkın aklınıza gelebilecek her şeyin
dibine kadar inerseniz atın vardı bir
tane gerçek sonuç vardır diyor O da
Aslında her şeyin bir hiç olduğudur
diyor bir şeyin var olduğuna inanmak
için bir düş kurmanız gerekir diyor
Bir daha söyleyeyim bir şeyin var
olduğuna inanmanız için bir düş kurmanız
gerekir İşte bu düş onu yüceltmek için
de olabilir yok etmek için de olabilir
diyor yani Aslında
alfreditrivinin yine kendisi söylediği
cümle ile Aslında hepimiz birer don
kişottur diyor eminim ki Don Kişot
hikayesini biliyorsunuzdur mutlaka
okumuşsunuzdur ama eğer okumadıysanız
bir kere daha okumanızı size tavsiye
ederim Çünkü
servantezi o kitapta Don Kişot ile
ilgili yazdığı bu muhteşem kitapta Don
Kişot'un atı rojinant diye öyle bir
anlatır ki Don Kişot'un gözünden
dünyanın gelmiş geçmiş en büyük atıdır o
aslında ayakta bile duramayacak olan
Sütçü beygiri değirmenlere dev diye
saldırdığı zaman Don Kişot sana çok
Panço der ki efendim onlar dev değil
onlar Değirmen
Ama sen şu Panço eşeğe biner anca
rojinanteye sadece ve sadece Don Kişot
biner Çünkü mesele sizin neyin nasıl
görmek istediğinizdir akıl her zaman
mutlak doğru değildir sizin Neyi nasıl
görmek istediğiniz son derece önemlidir
hayatınızı Buna göre endekslediğiniz
zaman o zaman bambaşka bir kapı aralıyor
önümüze babası hukukçu kuzeni hukukçu
kız arkadaşın hukukçu olan bir ailede
aykırı bir tane aktör devreye girmeye
başlıyor Geçen gün okulda bir öğrencimle
konuşuyorum Çok yetenekli bir kız var
okulda Gerçekten bak Bu arada ben Hacı
Bayram Veli Üniversitesi'nde Güzel
Sanatlar Fakültesi de ders veriyorum 2
yıldır Çok yetenekli Gerçekten bugün
tiyatro sahnelerinde büyük Star
olabilecek özellikleri birisi bize
fotoğraf video bölümünde okuyor Onu da
yönlendirmeye çalışıyorum Ne olur
oyunculuğa oyunculuk yapmaya çalış çok
yeteneklisin yani senin gibi bu mesleği
yapması lazım diye
tekrar ediyorum Dün dün hatta dün yani
bana dedi ki hocam Bizim ailemiz bunun
için uygun değil Benim ailem böyle bir
iş yapmama izin vermez Ben dedim ki
ailen mi vermez acaba Elalem mi vermez
Çünkü biz hayatımızı elaleme göre
endekslediğimiz için hayatımızda
başarılı olabileceğimiz birçok şeyi
yapmaktan da ne yazık ki feragat
ediyoruz Oysa ne istediğimiz ne yaptı
dediğimiz ne de başarılı olabileceğimiz
bizim için çok ama çok ama çok ama çok
önemli
Şimdi size bir şeyler söyleyeceğim
bununla beraber
hayatınızda sizi bir şey içer misiniz
diye sorduklarında çay kahve fark etmez
cevabını veriyor musunuz
var mı işinizde veren dürüstçe
söyleyeyim fark etmez
fark etmezse demek biliyor musunuz Ben
kararı veremiyorum benim yerime sen
karar ver demek Eğer hayatınızdaki bu
fark etmezleri hayatınızın içerisine
sokarsanız o zaman bir bakmışsınız siz
siz değilsiniz sizin yerinize başka
insanlar var sizin yerinize başka
insanlar karar veriyor bugün hala
hazırda farklı farklı üniversitelerde
okuyan Siz öğrenciler sadece anne
babaları Tesisleri akrabaları ya da
elalem istedi diye o okulda okuyup
başarısız oluyorlar Oysaki Ne
istediğinizi karar vermelisiniz Neyi en
iyi yaptığınızı bilmelisiniz geçenlerde
bir televizyon programında gördüm
çok hoşuma da gitti bu Türkiye'de
Ortaokulda lisede özellikle çocuğun
matematiği zayıfsa biraz matematik dersi
aldırılır biliyorsunuz Ben zayıfsa da
fena aldırılır ama edebiyatı iyi ise
edebiyat dersi aldırılmaz Oysa ki
yeteneklerinizi ortaya çıkartmalısınız
Eğer matematikte yetenekliyseniz daha
çok matematik çalışmalısınız edebiyatta
yetenektiyseniz daha çok edebiyat
çalışmalısınız sevdiğinizi keyif
aldığınızı daha çok yapmanız gerekiyor
bütün mesele bu başkalarının sizin için
karar vermesinden mutlaka kendinizi
uzaklaştırmanızı size abiniz olarak
tavsiye ediyorum Fark etmez başkasının
kararını vermek ama şimdi Biraz önce
söylediğim şeye de geri dönüyorum
alfrediyorum kitabını okuyup hayatını
değiştirdim kitap okumakta hayal etmek
demektir sakın unutmayın
şimdiki gençlerin en çok sevdiği
YouTube'da bir şeyleri seyretmek kitap
okumak yerine seyretmek devamlı
seyretmek seyretmek de başkasının
hayaliyle idare etmek demektir Eğer
başkasının hayaliyle idare ediyorsanız
kendi hayaliniz olmaz Kendi düşününüz de
olmaz Oysa ki bu ülkenin en çok ihtiyacı
olan şey bu Düşünmek düş kurmak hayal
etmek Hayal ettiğimiz zaman başarılı
olabiliriz
şimdi bir hukukçu aileden geliyorum
hukukçu Aileden sonra bir orkestrada
çalışmaya başladım çalıştığım orkestra
Bu arada Devlet Konservatuarı oyunculuk
bölümünde okuyorum şehir tiyatroların
orkestrasında çalışıyorum
Evita diye bir müzikal var bilirsiniz
herhalde değil mi duymuşsunuzdur evi
temizliklerinde Yani bir dönemin
yazılmış en büyük müzikallerinden bir
tanesi bu arada işte Lüküs hayatı
Keşanlı Ali Destanı işte Kuşlar
müzikleri bütün bu müzikallerin
orkestrasında çalışıyorum evi temizlik
Ali geldi evi temizlikleri ile beraber
Devlet Opera ve balesinin daha önce
genel sanat yönetmenliğini de yapmış
olan Pardon Genel Müdürlüğünde yapmış
olan sevgili Selman adada da 1989 Bu
arada yıllar 1989 yılında da bize şef
olarak geldi 4 tane ayrı Evi temiz var
Dünyada eşi benzeri olmaz şekilde
bir tanesi Zuhal Olcay bir tanesi
Arsenal gücü Zap bir tanesi Füsun Önal
ve bir tanesi de Dilek Türkali şimdi
Opera konusunda şöyle bir şey var bu
konuda çoğunuzun bilgisi olmayabilir ama
bir nota yazılıyor yazılan notaya göre
de orkestra çalıyor Yani yine şarkıcının
da önündeki nota var ve onu da okuması
gerekiyor fakat şarkıcıların bazıları
isim söylemeyeceğim Tabii ki bazılarının
sesleri yetmediği için bu sefer de
müzikte transpozisyonlar yapılıyor yani
ton değiştiriliyor ton değiştirilince de
şöyle bir acayip nokta olur Ben komşu
alıyorum en pessesesi mi Eğer bir ton
aşağıya alırsanız R çalmam lazım ama
enstrümanda öyle bir nota yok
enstrümanda Ona da olmayınca mecburen
bir ton Bir oktavi yukarıdan basmak
zorundasınız şimdi bu da bütün Aslında
müziğin yapısında değiştiren bir şey
Sen bana adaya bunu sordum ben ya hocam
biz transpozisyon yapıyoruz bu bir Opera
da transpozisyonu çok acayip bir şey
değil mi dedim yani bana dedi ki bak
oğlum dedi bu ülkede acayip bir durum
var dedi bu ülkede gidiyorsun dedi
bakkala pirinç almaya çalışıyorsun
pirincin içerisinde taş vardır dedi
kahveciye gidiyorsun kahvenin içerisine
un karış şey Ne o nohut karıştırmış dedi
mesele halkın pirinçle taşın unla Ya da
neyse işte nohutla kahvenin arasındaki
farkı bilmesidir dedi yani o yüzden Eğer
bilirseniz doğruyu isteyebilirsiniz
bilmezseniz O zaman işte böyle şeylerde
karşı karşıya kalırsınız kendinizi
bilinçlendirmek zorundasınız Ne
istediğinizi öğrenmek zorundasınız
aradaki farkları tespit etmek
zorundasınız ve Buradan sonra
evita'nın müzikalinden sonra ben artık
konservatuvarda bitirdim tiyatro
oyuncusu olarak hayata başladım Burada
çok acayip bir şey geldi başıma
son derece bozuk bu duruma Hani
konuşuyor ama aramızda birazcık mesafe
de var Avukat olmam lazımdı çünkü Avukat
olamadım yani başka bir hayatın
içerisinde hayatımı devam ettiriyorum
bir tane dizi film teklifi geldi bana
Türker inanoğlu'ndan
Sevginin Gücü dizi filminin ismi dizi
filmde de bir
seviyorum yeni bir cümle oldu ama bir
trans birey oynuyorum
1991 yılı yanlış hatırlamıyorsam Hülya
Avşar oynuyor
efendime söyleyeyim Tolga Savacı oynuyor
bayağı ünlü bayağı ünlü isimler oynuyor
televizyona çekilen bir dizi film Babam
geldi
İstanbul'a İzmir'den geldiler Annemle
beraber ben anneannemdeyim O zaman
toparlandık biraz soğukluk var ama hani
bir yandan da Okul da bitti nasıl
gidiyor oğlum dedi gayet iyi dedim bir
dizi film Çektin dedim hayırlısı dedi
Kimler var işte Hülya Avşar var şu var
bu hafta çok güzel dedi ne oynuyorsun
dedi baba transfer ediyorum dedim babam
kalp krizi geçiriyordu yemin ederim Size
ölüyordu babam yani korktum yani Ama onu
oynat yapacağım bir şey yok Olay
çıkarttı dedi kaç para aldıysan dedi git
dedi geri ver dedi yoksa param ben
veriyorum dedi oynamadım çektim baba
dedim yayına girecek bitti hikaye kızdı
Allah rahmet eylesin
Aslında mesele Şu mesele babamın beni
orada nasıl göreceği değil babam benim
ne olduğumu zaten Biliyor elaleme ne
diyecek koca avukat Erdinç sever Can'ın
oğlu böyle şeylerde ne işi var diyecek
fakat çok önemli Çok Usta isim
vermiyorum şimdi babamın da sınıf
arkadaşı olan çok değerli bir hukukçu bu
diziyi yayınlandıktan sonra babamı
arıyor diyor ki oğlunu seyrettim
dizi de diyor muhteşem oynamış ne iyi
oyuncu bir oğlum var senin diyor Sonra
babayı döndürdük bundan sonra Benim
yaptığımın aslında başka bir meslek
olduğunu bunu severek yaptığımı severek
yapıp başarılı olduğumu görünce Onun da
bu meslekle ilgili yakındığı her şeyi
değişti hepimizin hayatında birçok
başarı hikayesi olabilir az olabilir ama
hepimizin hayatında çok iyi biliyorum ki
çok fazla başarısızlık hikayesi de var
bugün burada sahneye çıkan ve tetikse
konuşulan bu başarıyı hikayelerinin
içerisinde o kadar çok başarısızlıklar
var ki emin olun O yüzden size yine bir
tavsiyem başarısız olduğunuz zaman
yılmayın başarıyı bulana kadar da
peşinden koşmaya çalışın bugün
bütün bu serüvenimden sonra biraz önce
sevgili üstadımla da konuştuk Bir
tiyatromuz var tam 17 yıldır bir
tiyatromuz var Şehir tiyatrolarında
başlayan serüvenim daha sonra benim
normal Tiyatrosu da geçti Normalde
Tiyatrosu kapana kadar orada çalıştım
akabinde tiyatro İstanbul Beşiktaş
Kültür Merkezi tiyatroya derken 17
yıldır tiyatro yapıyoruz
yıl boyunca pandemiden dolayı neredeyse
perde açamadık biliyorsunuz tiyatrolar
çok büyük zarar gördüler Bununla ilgili
Bütün bunlar varken de artık Yavaş yavaş
oynama imkanımız olduğunu öğrendiğimiz
zaman tiyatromuzu bir oyun koymaya karar
verdik herkes iki kişilik dekorsuz Aman
şöyle bir şey yapalım derlerken biz
Anton çehov'un Vişne Bahçesi oyununu
sahnelemeye karar verdik Şimdi atom işte
bacısı oyundaki farklı onu da size
söyleyeyim Bu da acayip gelebilir size
Zira
genellikle devlet tiyatrosunun ya da
Şehit tiyatrosunun ödeneklik
tiyatrolarının oynayabildiği çok dekorlu
çok kostümlü kalabalık kadroda Oyunlar
biz bunu yaptık ve şu anda yine sevgili
Esra'da eksik olmasın biraz önce
söylediği Yarın MEB Şura salonunda Ee
Rey Kore'nin yazmış olduğu bir far oyunu
to in the one 2'nin biri oyununu sadece
edeceğiz orada da çok ciddi bir kadro ve
çok ciddi bir dekor var Farklı yerlerde
farklı şeyler yapmaya başladık 17 yıldır
devam eden tiyatromuzu şu anda 60'a
yakın insan çalışıyor kendi istediğimizi
kendi sevdiğimiz oyunları oynayacağımız
bir dünyaya yarattık orada
bu dünyanın içerisinde de bir şeyleri
başarıp bir şeyleri devam ettirmeye
çalışıyoruz tiyatronun ismi Volkan
severcan Tiyatrosu falan değil sahne
Karlar koyduk tiyatronun ismini
hepimizin Tiyatrosu haline geldi Eğer
bir gün yolunuz düşerse bizim tiyatroyu
sizlere de mutlaka beklerim Esra'nın
söylediği bir şeye de buradan bir
gönderme yapmak istiyorum hani
hürriyetten 3 tane kart vardı ya sana
gelen içinizi biliyorum oyunculuk
yeteneği fazla olan bu mesleği yapmayı
çok isteyen çok insan olduğunu Benim
cebimde çok kartım yok ama oyunculuk
yapmak istiyorsanız bu mesleği yapmak
istiyorsanız ne olur deneyin bizim
tiyatromuz da size sonuna kadar her
zaman açık İyi ki varsınız iyi ki beni
dinlediniz Hepinize çok teşekkür
ediyorum
en büyük başarılarında sizlerin olmasını
temenni ediyorum
Sevgiyle kalın hoşça kalın
[Alkış]